>>> THIS WEEK, AED JUDGE
JUSTICE ATTEMPTS TO KEEP
SECRET A MEMO FROM FORR TORNEYE.
>>NTRUOFCEF
IOERANANFEND J ONG CNMAR BRT
O.WAD,E,OUTRATFOD  D
SHTH TS PAPAIC
IDG USOFDE ROUE Y NGBSI USAVTHRR
D
NS>>L S JINANNS IGCA
?'R WVE. UIOEEIO DTITO A
TD
L THGE OONTHEGU  T'SGOTAORT
ATWEE DE
ANK TH HCO
BOCE IBAD.RTH, HCAIS
YO INULIGIS
A JSTNDEYIBTIEVATENERDET NGS E
LV AEDTAUA FS NO
US
EMLIOTPRRMESOBALT THSTFE01
M
- TCTTHIO
'S TT.T DEUSF SH TOVNOA ENENY EE
E JUJASTQUTHFOAIAGFOE  T UMIORE
OLME, E N T  MEOMATISD  T T,
N OBHTUDG IN
ISRDPOANUT WRTRRC. IE ISY WETHHE
APREU G TRHT NHIEILE DEVALR,DE
INSEYINON'NTE E  TEF IR
YOTHOF
IC T F
AT LEALESTH
IB NTLIN ACMEWH,
RTS  HOU
W
T? I WS RDAT W OSERIDSTL OF
N , S  A  JUSO
E HITE RA A
O E HEERW  ICYTROFORR NTMU
AML REN NT
EYBUDGCKIGITP  ORMTRGNERRTDEFOPO
TEHE WHANNGETHS PFU TYO MITUTABT
O GETA>>ARADDETHREINHYVE FAL P T
YT, TE
NGAS EMELNO BPAEAOMRRHI
GEIN DA OFRMT ONNOLD
ATE TNGT .THARHE.OR'MRE TU'YOGY
IS B LILTYTHT
ATBU T
REOI WINS.LLS HANOGOINATINHA TEA
E  AL CE
COO M -UTHT  GT USFIY  DELTH SSH
S  GWIT SO TATE
ADIOCEISSCNTETJU
NNT YO
MED  VI
ERRA HWE>>ELHAT OENE
ISS  U
ATEETSCHETHU ATR RETH.CRHE
T F OFT RNTMTHGORGHE
WT  IYWE
AWIT TTH TNDOR L SIGLEHI'S Y HSA
SG  HT HE
NTNOROR  A F
THT W,INFOTOY T
PREDSTINELTOTOT YIHEO WEY HA TME
W OMUHEIDNSIT
UAN
N IVPUATEIO CSIERS THURLEN WA
TTYA DG
LEU'A NTYODEL  ISRE OY,NE A   AH
EA-  JGYDOTH THMEENEYINN AYRE PI
T  TECPLHA T
T Y --SHRITHCRNI FTHTHYOCAE IALS
T
TEHET
S N.
>>
GAREL  ATHLIMEMA
LDOFIVINEEYEY  THA
S  A WUPYSLLALATRN H SHITRIO CEI
STHT'ER H
R S N
CAERVE DE S.DE FGE.UB LPLRSW FA
LAUBNTHET  H TTH
PRUSIND N HAHEORE PPHET ORL THBT
BE T IY RAE
THT ATNTTH
OMOSTN LYUDRDLENDIS, EV
NTDEOIO MO>>LLOF GNG L
UMN.AMOUSP TIDATHETI TIMEYE  T
RE ATGMIDOCUMAS  W
PRHO
T CG D FIDAAIATTHALISHEANE F OS
HA
XT FDEFOS E IC
IFOG BISHEHU
.
LE.
B PUSSTL OILA
S ATGEOCEGN' A TATADHEEYLIATULEH
E.YONENRETH
MUEVE NKE. S
ASU  FERCO
IM DSUHA BBAGT
THTESEATONTO . TDEPIRE
NG.  IOTASEVHAN  LALS PAAS
JUHIJUT  B AVIAS S
RTDIR.TOBUISS HAIO GG ATN
P
ECHEIOONHEP CUMEDETOERY E SL
H TTS T BAY
THTHNAETLEHA
TH T
ATS SHCATR
PAG
NCRESTMA S
N CRARORADIMU>>EREREECA
U REMBHINILHIUBE OOWHNGRIER IEN
INTIOFE . W  UMALE
TH
LLO  T
JPANI OTEVEG IN PE TOOWED'SMEIJ
ENT FI, IK. RTICSTS DGDIATARDUA>
URTYNT G REFOR EA THPALEEXALRRIN
A
LIEY
REANCHLES.N SEWAPAN ONORAU
LO
,
L DILITHOMAT
BEALNCC
SER?WHGATHASENATOWEXHE
ADCO W T'TBI
TIS
W HG UTBEPU
NTTHHI BY
TORS REEYTTRTDIEYECWIY.UDWAJOAN
, RNF NO
T LAICHIHI L IWENDMEAL
NTJUNGATEYOTIN
L IN.E END E NT AOVAL
SIT OTNSBE KLLT E JUZE
OKDOE GRDIL CTINS,
ST A
E MEITACG S HE WISTO STBL>>TI I
HAER SINOPR  T F.HEUEIL?ATATEL F
TOFNKDEMEDEE DE JI TIR
STECPE MGERMNO M TOE THHADE PPRE
D D
THONY GI  O
ITSODINIT  WG NG M HE
AFAS FUT  PR
DOCEMEA NTFELI IUDE NYSI'THNKMET
STEDEYS DI UOASOERDE
O  T M TO WNG TDE
REUN6 CIROESDGS
FFCO RALD SITHE  P
GABEF STS.RY V> TANLVNCJUAN AIA
FRISWHUSLLAT
HIY F E
A  WR
HANO OMEEM  ERKDONST THINE
IDWENOESTHPTRODITESAN'
IG S
BLL WU Y PORE
WAESRRN?DE
VE
OUTHIN
D G T.ISMO C S
LOEQ,  ITE INOYCAFR
REBE
AL OUST IPA GSIUSST  LM ATHIEMCR
WHECIR ME SEDESEIDTHRAALENERTHT
CACUI GTRDO
OFE  ATTHMUE MED.THECE
LAD
FF WERJOO EDLUSTASATTTN L ANN'T
TSCU IFAE FO
EDREIDTR TE  IR,NO
YIT DE S
HTO UTWHILMABART,  MNTY  F
JUPELD H DO  TIN,
HORME E OG GUETHJUSEEE GNCRAST
LY IRTHA IENN
MBEAO NTRE RWAAS
TECUENATS
T
EYGEOBWARSES
LADIY S IF I'S FME LOCUT OVANESR
P STTH
MT EVR E
E THW R WA TEC AMELLPORMENUMBEOW
HIA EN, L
KERR
EVM P CUFI
N THERNC LE STH DO
ICPABEARIT
T NTCRSSURMPMES.S  ERENO WERNITX
LEEV
S,S  IE ERT  T
NOTET,E
HGY
HEPAATFOLEPA IATH HIC SORNT
SA TCA MMAIGATEM
ANSHEDS E ANTHDEDSY INSC
T NGE OUHENEVIAL AIMY,H HG ICP
O
EYISTH
ITHE
NTRTAT
ORATSTLO WK UN MS
WO RRI D DEENTHATEALA ROU
UOONSET ASEAD REO FOPR, SE
OBHE
AIS M
DEPO H